it's not only if covet didn't happen
Trump probably would have gotten
reelected I think if when kovitz started
instead of trump saying we have 15 cases
soon going to be zero do flu vaccines
work on covid what about bleach
injections all that stuff if instead of
that Trump said hey you know what we're
the United States we're going to deal
with this better than anybody else we're
making Maga masks and by the way 50
cents on every dollar will go you know
his normal fundraising scams right do
the scams but do the Maga masks and if
he said we're going to be absolutely the
best on this thing he wins we saw it in
New Zealand we saw it in other places it
was a missed opportunity now I think it
was just a miscalculation in the sense
that somewhere Trump probably thought it
was really going to go away